[Applause]
we could talk about uh gilay maxwell
news this is kind of crazy her trial oh
did you know about this no
there's an account that was tracking the
trial of elaine maxwell on twitter
right giving updates et cetera twitter
suspended the account yes now what are
the details this because on the surface
it looks crazy the ceo of twitter jack
dorsey stepped down right before the
trial started i don't know if you saw
that [ __ ] oh yeah a little convenient
very a little convenient now all of a
sudden they're giving us details about
this glen maxwell trial and trial
right
they're giving us details about it and
all of a sudden suspended the twitter
account what's the real here mark all
right so basically corner conspiracy
there's a clue there's this twitter
account
we up in the production value yeah yeah
all right ready go mark cause here's
your corner yeah so from the conspiracy
corner basically there's a website
called or this twitter account called
tracker trial and they started two weeks
ago and it had half a million followers
in two weeks
and then the account and all the
accounts that were registered to this
individual that was running all these
different trackers
got this notice from twitter saying you
have violated our rules against platform
manipulation and spam you may not use
twitter services in a manner intended to
artificially amplify or suppress
information or engage in behavior that
manipulates or disrupts people's
experience on twitter
so they were spamming people they're
basically saying that the account was
trying to manipulate or spam on the
platform
by giving
details about it like honestly
they probably had like a bunch of
accounts and so
their site will post something
other ones it and make it look like it's
a big story uh so this looks crazier
than it really is that's what twitter's
a legend now the person that runs it is
a uh it's basically an account called i
can't remember the exact guy oh
i can't remember the oh the free press
report so it's like a team of people
that basically have different trackers
that track different people doing things
you know throughout the internet so they
have a nancy tracker for nancy pelosi
that tweets her investments over time
so like keep tabs and make sure there's
like a watchdog for different people and
groups that they're trying to keep tabs
i like this this is good so they're
saying that twitter is alleging that
they're using the platform in the way
that they don't want them to use it so
it's not just this account was taken
down there are multiple accounts
this is the one that is getting
highlighted obviously because it looks
like they're trying to cover their [ __ ]
up because they [ __ ] cover this [ __ ]
up okay but i like the idea that we
could follow nancy pelosi yeah i feel
like that should be public knowledge to
everyone this is just making that public
knowledge even easier yeah it is public
knowledge they were just tweeting it out
every time she did something so it was
making it easier like yesterday yeah and
there's acceptable public now there's a
bunch of these different like watchdog
accounts but i like that i don't want to
have to go to the library or go to
wherever the [ __ ]
yeah maybe keep an eye on the dewey desi
i don't even know how to use a dewy desi
bro yeah i do you know how to use the
dewey decimal system yeah no chance you
have you look at the number and ask the
genre
what the [ __ ] did you just say you look
at the number on the dewey decimal and
then that's the genre of the book and
then you go in there
yeah
i don't know if that's really how it
works that seems like how it probably
works
it gives you a number the last three you
go to the shelves and that's the number
you refer to exactly yeah stupid yeah
but you don't know the genre based on
the numbers
no it isn't all of that [ __ ] no it isn't
yeah
you [ __ ] numb nuts
dude don't be such a num-num technology
600 science is 500.
psychology's 100 religions 200.
yeah it's simple math nah bro you make
that [ __ ] up no no
yeah
dude don't you ever disrespect me yeah
you disrespected me
you said that my head was a dick
dressing like adam sandler don't you
ever disrespect me my girl calls this my
shrek shirt bro
shrek [ __ ]
nah that shout out to nems bro nems is
this dude i shared you all on that yeah
yeah i posted yesterday but he does
these things absolutely he's this rapper
he's a guy that popularized bing bong on
a side talk and uh and like he's rapper
i think from like queens
or maybe
coney island and um
and he does these things where like
people just walking by the street he
just roasts them yeah but don't you ever
disrespect me looking like mary kate and
ashley if they were crackheads or
something like that like as the
crackheads walking down the street to
their face to their faces holding the
phone doing it and bro is [ __ ]
hilarious don't you ever disrespect me
that's how he starts don't you ever
disrespect looking like a character from
futurama yeah
just murdering [ __ ] don't you
ever dismiss it looking like you about
to host a battle rap with eminem and it
was a black dude with
he's dreads these [ __ ] bro
check his ass out man you want to pull
it up yeah
no no no no no yeah yeah yeah
do we got some audio what's that [ __ ]
don't ever disrespect me looking like
wolverine in the lower east side you're
hurt
don't ever disrespect me out here
looking like a sloth
that's good i don't even disrespect me
looking like tails from the crypt
yo jerry garcia
don't ever disrespect me yeah
y'all don't ever disrespect me looking
like a dominican gill again you're hurt
disrespect me wearing jenko jeans in
2021 yeah y'all don't ever disrespect me
looking like snoop dogg joey badass and
tupac
[Laughter]
tibetan buddhist statue
he got a bunch of these yeah it's an
amazing follow that's great it's just
absolutely [ __ ] hysterical don't ever
disrespect me though
i meant that sincerely okay so what are
we making this man so maybe they were
legitimately spamming maybe there's a
bunch of these accounts okay a couple
things can happen let's go conspiracy
vibes on it right what if this was a
convenient excuse
to get an account out of here that's
exposing information about this trial
yeah so twitter and their community
guidelines can basically put a bunch of
[ __ ] that every account's violated yeah
and that's how they that's how they can
create some sort of security on there
and if anybody's ruffling feathers they
go oh by the way you have curses in your
tweets yeah this is hate speech the
busta headlight
now do you think that that's really what
it is or do you think that they were
legitimately spamming and this brought
so much light to their spam operation
well i don't know because there's other
maxwell trial trackers and they're still
there i think there's other accounts
that are like tracking the trial like
obviously that's what i'm saying
couldn't you just text that [ __ ] to
somebody else and have him post it now
that's the new maxwell trial tracker
yeah i mean like there's other like
trial tracker accounts in general like
they have sauger is doing it but
oh how is soccer doing it well i mean
he's like reporting on the trial right
right but he got to get information from
somebody right somebody's got to leak
this information because it's probably
trial no it doesn't have to necessarily
be leaked like they have like court
reporters and like people in the trial
like writing about it they just don't
have a television so this is just making
it harder for the public to access this
information and if you're
somebody that's
okay in the most legal sense of the word
if you're somebody that's on gillane's
team maybe her team is like yo get all
this information out of here the last
thing we want to do is sway the jury
last thing we want is tons of people
talking about what's happening in the
trial making her look worse than she
already looks right they would probably
want that wait keep they
[Music]
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
i gotta make sure your dicks are hard
okay that's my personal responsibility
and you know who's gonna help me do this
blue chew blue chew same active
ingredient that's inside cialis or
viagra but this is the true this is the
one we rock with and this is the reason
i'm getting married okay it's the reason
the boys on this podcast are already
married bluetooth.com make sure you use
that promo code andrew and you're gonna
get it for free all you gotta do is pay
five dollars for shipping that's it
enjoy bluetooth.com go there go do it
now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip that you can see the whole
episode at patreon.com that's flagrant
too
oh yo that's a great why don't they try
to do that why don't they try to say
tainted jury or poisoned jury i mean
that's why the jury has to stay off
social media the internet they're not
supposed to look at the news and [ __ ]
like that when they're on the trail
right and high profile trials they'll
put them up in like hotels and so they
can't even interact with other people
until so who would want to be one of
those jurors i mean you
you don't got the choices that's your
civic duty yeah you've never been a jury
i've been jury duty they ain't called me
into the [ __ ] probably not why yeah
probably why not he just voiced his
opinions i think yeah
they just ask you and you just tell them
how you feel honestly one of the size
doesn't want me there because i know i'm
too good at knowing who did it and who
you know i mean i have such a good
insight about it
you might have a feeling you got a good
gut bro you got a good gut you never did
jury dude i've tried
how do you try i went to it where did
they go i didn't they never called me
never called me i was just chilling
there on the phone all day eight hours a
day yeah just chilling dead ass and they
were like why are you here not even no
they know why you're there but that you
go like 200 people go to the courtroom
or whatever and then they'll call in
select numbers of people he's just
saying he showed up without anyone
telling me yeah i didn't nobody showed
nobody told me to be he just showed up i
was just trying to do my civic duty this
guy loves america i love america you
have america i'm american enlisted it's
not a draft you enlisted yeah up my
draft card yeah yeah you know what i
mean now they said they were gonna
arrest me if i didn't go because i
missed it so many times
so i i made a deal with him i made a
plea i plea i played it out
what was that
he was there i'm still working there
wait really
that's what he was still working there
that's right i remember i got the [ __ ]
downstairs then i came up to your like
office when you were on injury yeah yeah
yeah that's right oh y'all were already
working together at this point yeah yeah
oh okay i thought i thought that should
change your life i was like yo your jury
duty got this man changed his life no i
was still on it i was that'd have been
way cooler of a story that would have
been you got him acquitted
he got you free to him
couldn't get me off dirt jury duty
nothing back to maxwell what do we think
about this so um i think it's possible
that this was maybe the most famous uh
account there was being it was tracking
the trial and they needed an excuse to
get the [ __ ] out of here found something
that they violated and they're like boom
you're out of here yeah clearly they
want to protect
maxwell i mean i don't even know why
we're debating that like clearly they
want to protect maxwell they want to
protect uh whoever they is but they want
to protect uh the people that epstein
had dirt on they wouldn't have killed
his ass if they didn't want to so if
there's somebody who's willing to kill
epstein while he's in prison there's
clearly somebody out there who's
powerful enough to want to protect
gillian yeah like we don't have to
debate this this we know is fact already
just looking at names on epson's plane
somebody going to want these guys out of
here yeah how to protect them or
whatever 100
interesting who do you think is going to
be the next person that goes down for
this that we know of not goes down like
in terms of being guilty but like which
one of our friends will be compromised
like if soccer covers this enough do you
think that something weird is going to
happen to sauger
he's not big enough i don't think yet
yeah i think you got to keep going a
little bit i think you got to ruffle
some feathers before i get this guy out
of here i mean
i don't know like those security guards
that worked in the whatever
at the police station i guess they were
just the ones who were there but they
they must have gotten taken care of in
some kind of way yeah yeah yeah but
they're not are you saying
are they going to take down one of our
friends or pay them off yo they paid
them off but if they didn't accept
payment oh they take them down they're
going to take them down
because they want that guy dead
so it's not like they come up in the
back we'd like to pay you to murder this
guy they go we're gonna pay you to
murder this guy and if you say no
some bad [ __ ] might happen to you just
keep looking at their accounts and if
sagar suddenly stops sweeting about the
trial or somebody's like you know i
don't think she did it sagar the
pressure's on you my boy yeah you gotta
keep your foot on this [ __ ] you're at a
breaking point my friend yes you're
going out i saw what you did right there
that was good the prison guards that got
paid off or fell asleep or whatever they
got no jail time of course not shocking
they got arrested or like they got i
guess like indicted for their like
involvement but they didn't get fired
i think so yeah because also they got a
union that's crazy
they were just being lazy on the job you
get fired but you're not made in
committee you're saying like if there's
no proof that they committed a crime
they just did their job shitty and they
should get fired or whatever the union
agrees they should be put on suspension
yeah
oh yeah that would make sense twitter
accounts
though on instagram
so that twitter account's still active
on instagram though which one trial
tracker
another interesting thing about epstein
that a lot of people don't talk about is
that he went when they first got
arrested he was like thinking oh shit's
all good like i'm gonna get out and then
when the judge didn't set bail
he tried to commit suicide that first
night so he had a suicide attempt
and then they put him on suicide watch
when you're supposed to have a jail mate
with another person with you at all
times and so that person like i think
got moved the night before or some [ __ ]
like that and they were just the staff
was just too lazy to
put somebody else down that's convenient
but yeah that's a [ __ ] that is like
looks convenient but it's like oh he
tried to offer himself a couple days for
a fact he tried
i mean
even if they're saying he tried to offer
himself though that actually makes it
more egregious that you ever let him be
alone because he tried to kill himself
once so why would you ever leave him
alone why would you ever not have the
whole point of suicide watch is let's
make sure 24 hours a day this
[ __ ] didn't kill himself he's
already tried once so
if i'm absent and i'm alone
i'm a fake commit suicide so they put me
with someone because i know they're
coming for me
um i think he's doing that
like these [ __ ] gonna get me
out of here it's just me in here and he
was right yep so i'd fake commit suicide
do whatever the [ __ ] you have to do put
the [ __ ] around your neck you know like
uh kick your feet on the ground a bunch
make some [ __ ] noise spit some stuff
up they're like oh this guy's on a
suicide watch they got to go through the
protocol right they go through the
protocol and now you're in a room
they're supposed to have a celly with
he's like where's my celly at oh no
selly tonight guard's looking sleepy
game over yeah
finish the
that's job makes it interesting because
it can go both ways man i've seen these
pictures of [ __ ] analyzing his
earlobes and [ __ ] y'all seen this yeah
like the
the the dead epstein has like different
ears
than the live epstein
every every like replacement like avril
lavigne got replaced with titties
she said got some fat tits and all of a
sudden that's what people are suggesting
is that she got replaced with someone
with just super heavies really that's a
good that's an upgrade that's not a
replacement upgrade for us if you get
heavier in that department unless you're
levine then now you're super dead super
dead so someone killed avril lavigne i
mean she was annoying she was a skater
girl was it kyle rynnos guys
guys let's just calm down but they do
that with everyone too soon like any
time there's a replacement thing like
look at the ears look at the nose the
facial structure i'm like
it seems convenient but i also don't
understand what are they going to do
when these kardashians die bro
and they're just putting the old picks
yeah kylie and this is the kylie died
there's no way
my favorite maximal conspiracy so far is
the reddit account okay guys no so
there's a reddit account oh this is
early and this is brilliant and it's
like gotten crazier like more and more
people have done more research on it but
there's a reddit account called maxwell
hill yeah they have like the eighth most
karma of all time ever on reddit explain
karma so basically like karma's your
points you get from posting on the
platform like the more you post the more
karma you get if your posts are good
right so she is like the eighth most
karma of all time like algorithmic
confidence yeah basically they have a
metric for it yeah yeah and she's like a
power mod she's like on top of like all
the biggest subreddits on reddit which
we look at reddit as like oh this is
like a corny little website but it's
like one of the biggest websites no i
don't look at it like that at all it's
like massive yeah and so many people go
to it for information on like what they
should be reading yeah and so she was in
charge like world news technology all
this [ __ ] on the day galen maxwell was
arrested
there was not a post
since
on that reddit account even though there
were posts nearly every day of her 14
years up until the day that she was
arrested oh [ __ ] the gaps in posting
line up with maxwell's mother's death
and her funeral
um the posts on the account never
mentioned anything about jeffrey epstein
despite her being a moderator of world
news
she goes around correcting the ages of
consent and various comments throughout
the platform over the years uh post
articles about why we should legalize
child exploitation material again i
don't necessarily know what that
material was but that's what this like
bullet says
gripes about overzealous protection laws
she was raised in the uk at headington
hill hall so some people are saying that
her post that her account is maxwell
or hill yeah um
and then she puts her birthday in one of
the accounts saying that like her
birthday's in december which matt galea
maxwell's birthday's in december
and uh
yeah also this is like a modern source
of news right right and you can control
narratives with news and who would know
that better than the daughter
of the news magnate
i mean robert maxwell was like a rupert
murdoch type was he not yeah in the uk
so of course she's got the not only the
backing but the know-how and the people
of influence that can help her help her
do it the whole time matter of fact she
could probably drop crazy stories
information
on [ __ ] before it ever drops in a
newspaper or any other kind of social
outlets yeah and so to this day all the
posting history is still up
but hasn't posted since she got arrested
that's super weird sorry how she build
up such karma if she's clearly posting
all this creep [ __ ]
what do you mean like correcting people
on the ages of consent that's a good
point saying child exploitation law
should be material should be legal well
she's not obviously saying that directly
but that's how it can be interpreted so
like she's going in the comments and
people are like oh well in this country
malaysia it's this and she's like well
actually technically it's you know 16
years old or whatever but you wouldn't
make sense of it if you didn't think she
was a pedophile but now that she is it's
like oh okay it's like when you find out
somebody might be gay and now you look
at the outfits they were wearing they're
like oh that was a little sus yeah why
was he wearing a only leather jacket
that's weird yeah just tell me
what what
we don't think you're gay we just think
you have a boxing match you're losing
weight for yeah
yeah bro
there's no match to missy bro it's what
omasha missy missy elliot she passed
away um
what
she did geez i'm scared dude
yeah i was [ __ ] up like
you tried to kill missy like that oh no
that was a little bit crazy y'all need
to chill the [ __ ] out there you
disrespect us okay so what do we think
ultimately happens with maxwell
she's gonna beat this [ __ ]
and then we're not gonna see her for a
while and we'll be fascinated and let's
be there and we won't care yeah we'll
move right the [ __ ] along we'll care
about it for two weeks we'll move on for
a little bit it'll be a little thing in
the back of the back of all the noise
like in the background yeah and then
it'll end up being a joke just like
epstein didn't kill himself what up
people you just watch a clip from our
weekly patreon episode you can support
the flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
you